what's going on everybody so in this
video i'm going to talk about the one
thing i probably get asked more than
anything else
which is what is the best college degree
or major
for a data science career now i can't
give
one single answer to this that's going
to work for absolutely everybody
but what we're going to do here is we're
going to look at a survey done by 365
data science
so they did research into 1001 data
scientists from
all around the globe over the years 2018
to 2020.
now the findings from this are really
interesting so we're going to talk about
that
then i'm going to give you some overall
principles behind
selecting a degree and just how the
knowledge from that is going to
translate into a data science job in the
first place
please note i'm not a professional
career advisor this video is for
entertainment purposes
and to hopefully give you some useful
food for thought if this is your first
time here
my name is richard subscribe to my
channel for all kinds of content just
like this if you haven't already
and hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm now if we look just at the
year 2018
notice a lot of these people are pretty
new on the job right
they have between zero and 12 months of
experience or maybe one to two years
well the most common area of study
appears to be computer science
that's pretty closely followed by stats
and math
that's followed by econ and social
sciences
and now this one actually kind of
surprised me
uh but it's pretty consistent with what
a lot of you guys are telling me
because a lot of you guys you come from
econ backgrounds and you ask does it
make more sense
to transition into another field but
appears that econ in general is one of
the most common fields for
breaking into data science then there's
a pretty noticeable drop-off
the next most common one is data science
and analysis
so that's all pretty interesting but if
we go over to the year 2019
notice there's a little bit of a drop
off for stats and math
it's fallen to the number three spot
behind econ and social sciences
and computer science is still in the
number one spot
but then things get really interesting
when we look at the year 2020
so in this year data science and
analysis
skyrockets to the number one spot as an
area of study
computer science is still number two
behind that ahead of
stats and math or econ and social
sciences
but this is really interesting and now
my first thought upon looking at this
might be well data science is such a new
field of study
it might have taken until the year 2020
just for people to get those degrees and
for that to be reflected in the
workplace
but no because even if you look at these
people with like three to five years of
experience
data science and analysis is still in
the number one spot here so
so this to me was absolutely fascinating
so that's all well and good if you're
able to get a data science degree
you're likely to develop a pretty
multi-disciplinary set of skills
that's going to pay enormous dividends
for you as you launch your career
here's the problem though so here in the
u.s
and i'm sure the situation is similar in
countries like the uk
or india for instance not all colleges
offer data science majors so i'm not
totally sure how accurate this
particular blog is
and i know it's going back almost a
couple years now
but they compiled a list of all the
major colleges they could find that
offer data science majors
and as i was scrolling through this list
there were a few
high-profile colleges that stood out to
me as
not being on this list as offering data
science majors
and some of them are pretty new like
even the school i graduated from the
university of michigan for instance
the data science program there is pretty
new going back to like
2015 or 2016. so all that to say
there's absolutely no guarantee the
school that you want to go to
or in the us whatever school happens to
be in your state
is going to offer a data science program
let's suppose
your school doesn't offer a data science
program well
what then now i actually want to start
this discussion off with an
anecdote so one of the best applied data
scientists and research scientists
i've ever known guy works at google now
his compensation is in several hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year
he actually came from a physics
background now he did get a phd
and everything but physics is not
exactly the type of degree that you
think of
the things you learn in that degree
translating directly into data science
and i think for the most part he would
probably agree with you
but here's the thing he considered that
degree to be one of the best decisions
he'd ever made
because he said the degree helped him to
problem solve
and just to critically think and solve
unstructured
problems so well and that's the thing
if you look at any of these top degrees
so
things like data science computer
science stats math
econ social sciences engineering even
in all of these degrees that's exactly
what you're doing
you're solving challenging often unclear
unstructured types of problems and
you're just building those
muscles in your brain to be able to do
that and so that's why
honestly with a lot of these degrees
you're not really going to go wrong
your path might look a little less
linear it might be a little bit
different from
others but either way if you want bad
enough to develop the skill sets for
data science and you come from
from any of these backgrounds you're
going to be able to
but then a lot of people even if they
haven't launched their careers off yet
they're familiar with the
conceptualization of data science being
at the intersection of stats
and computer science granted
communication and domain expertise work
into that too but that's neither here
nor there
so they'll ask the question which is a
better program
stats or computer science if you
absolutely have to pick one
now my answer to that one is going to be
a little bit biased because
i come from a stats background myself
but if i had to absolutely pick between
those two
i would go with the stats and the reason
for that is
i would rather be a data scientist who's
strong at stats but a little bit weaker
on computer science
than the other way around because let's
think about it
if you have that stats background you
know the fundamentals
you know models so you know different
ways to attack problems and you know how
to interpret results
sure you don't necessarily know all the
cs fundamentals
and algorithms out there but you can
pick up sql
you can pick up r or python you're going
to be pretty employable
on the other hand though if you're
strong at computer science
but you don't know statistics at all or
you're weak in that
it's easy for you to get into the
territory i like to call data
pseudoscience
you know what i mean that is you can
start misinterpreting
things not knowing the right ways to
approach problems and things can get
ugly
so again you're going to be in a good
position with either of these two but
again if you have to pick one i would go
with the stats
now obviously there are a number of
caveats behind all of this
the first one that i'm going to point
out is you should always pick a degree
in something that interests you
and something that you're going to like
so for instance with stats
if you absolutely hate stats it just
it's boring to you
that's not something that you should
probably major in and in fact
you probably want to rethink going into
data science in the first place if
that's the case for you
and then the other thing is particularly
if you're going into a data science
program
it's brand new for a lot of colleges and
universities
so try to make sure that your school is
conducting it properly
and now for this you might be able to do
this just by gleaning through all the
course requirements and descriptions
but failing that sit down with an
advisor and talk in detail about the
program
if you're going into a data science
program you do need to be learning
statistics
and i did a whole video on how much
statistics you need for data science
i'll have that linked in the description
but in short
you should be learning probability
calculations and bayes rule
the central limit theorem things like
the confidence interval and hypothesis
testing frameworks
things like how sampling structure and
bias affect
problems and then various linear
modeling approaches
you need to be getting some exposure to
sql ideally
and you should be learning one of r or
python preferably both
but if you learn only one of them that's
okay then ideally
if this program exposes you to things
like linear algebra
uh communication and human centered
design principles
as well as machine learning you're gonna
be in a good position
so at the end of the day just do your
due diligence
there are a lot of bad programs out
there
and before you go dropping tens of
thousands of dollars especially if
you're going into debt to do so
just do some research so if your school
does offer a data science program
that's probably going to be the best
single option you can pick
but there's no one path that every data
scientist
must go down and in fact i did a video
all about how
you can become a data scientist with no
college degree at all
granted a degree is going to help the
vast majority of people
and some employers do require it but it
is possible to get your foot in the door
without that college degree
so at the end of the day pick something
that you're going to enjoy
where you're learning skills that are
going to be valuable in the marketplace
whether that's in data science data
analytics or whatever else
and you're going to do just fine so
thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it hit the like button
please consider sharing the video
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then richard on data